for
e e
spe
e for
let's try that again welcome welcome
everybody Welcome to the table welcome
everyone online we're so glad you're all
here with
us the wonderful Allison hoe is our
events Ministry team team lead and she
is looking for some folks to serve on
that team so you would help organize
potlucks do service projects and other
events that the table hosts if you're
good at that sort of thing which I am
not then please scan the QR code and
fill out the contact form link and let
us know that you're interested Alison ho
needs some help
all right we have another announcement
here the not your mam Sunday school
class began today at 3:00 and we'll be
running through November the 24th it's
an hour and a half class where we will
read through the gospel of Mark in a
safe space and ask hard theological
questions it's the perfect space if you
are deconstructing or wrestling with how
a view scripture
or simply want to learn more about the
[Music]
Bible also on Sunday November the
17th this is a big one guys we will be
celebrating our 5year anniversary as a
church yeah so mark your
calendars it will be a special time
where we'll have some folks share their
story stories and then directly after
the service we'll have a chili cook off
if y'all have ever been to a chili
cookoff man you need to put this on your
calendars and you need to dust off your
recipes and uh bring your get your that
favorite recipe ready cuz we're will be
looking forward to having your
chili all
right now we'll settle in for
worship the candles that we have lit are
aign the presence of Christ Among
Us fully human and fully
Divine so let us come joyfully before
Christ for God knows us and loves
us let us come prayerfully before Christ
for God sees our concerns and our
fears let us come hopefully before
Christ for Christ proclaims God's love
and forgiveness for all of God's
people know throughout your whole being
that God absolutely loves
you enter this time to behold Christ the
revelation of God the heartbeat of
creation and allow Grace to find
you to mend your heart
may we come
[Music]
home thank you JY would you guys go
ahead and stand with us we're going to
sing some songs together at the
beginning of our service here and uh
it's such a gift um this space and time
with you guys each week to be able to
lift our voices to be able to lift our
hearts and uh believe that God is here
in our midst and he is the great
connector he is the common thread he is
our source and if you are here and you
are breathing then he is with you he is
with us and you are welcome in the space
so let's sing these words as a um as a
declaration as a praise a Thanksgiving
to him that he is our way he is our
source and he is keeping our feet from
suffering right
I Love You
Lord you have delivered
me I love you
Lord you have delivered my soul from
Death my from
stumbling I will walk in the land of Liv
my from my from
in the of the
[Music]
[Applause]
living I love you Lord
you have Liv
me I love you
Lord you have delivered my soul from my
from
stumbling I will walk in the land of the
living my
soul my Fe from
stum I will the of the
[Music]
living I Will Bless I Will Bless You
Lord For You Heard My Cry I reach out my
hand and save my life I Will Bless You
Lord For You H my and the god of Heaven
turn to me I will bless you Lord for an
ending love for your grace and mercy R
down from above I will bless you to the
very end I will call on you and I may
live I Love You
Lord you have Liv
[Applause]
Me Love You
Lord you have delivered my
soul
[Applause]
mying I will in the land of the living
my soul from Death my feet from stum I
will walk in the of the
[Music]
Liv all right kids yall are dismissed to
go to your classes with your teachers
they'll meet you over there by the
doors and a big thank you to our kids
ministry team thank you so much Katie
and
Maggie Harper
so many other people back there in the
nursery so grateful for
them and we are going to transition into
the prayers of the people so if you guys
would follow along on the screens and
read the words in R aloud and then we'll
take space to offer up what you carry
into this space before God and each
other hold that before
him Jesus for this city of saxi Texas
and for every city and community and all
who live in them we pray to you for the
Good Earth you have given us and the
wisdom and the will to conserve it we
pray to you for the old and the sick for
the Widow and the orphan for the injured
and suffering we pray to you for the
poor and the oppressed the unemployed
and destitute for prisoners and captives
and all who remember and care for them
we pray to you for the vulnerable
the marginalized and those unjustly
targeted for their gender sexuality race
or other perceived difference we pray to
you for those experiencing loss
loneliness and disconnection and for
those struggling with mental and
emotional health we pray to you Lord we
know that you love us and that you hear
us and so we lift these names and
situations up to you
[Music]
for the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts Hearts we pray
to you that they may have life and light
healing and hope peace and a deep sense
of your
presence
[Music]
amen so before we begin the song I just
wanted to share a little bit about what
I'm experiencing right now this moment
just a little bit of nervousness anxiety
and just feeling overwhelmed with life
you know like it's such a busy
season and
sometime it just like it feels like I
can't keep up like I'm not good
enough but I know that's not the
truth so I just want to lay it
down and uh yeah I just invite the Lord
in so uh yeah forgive me
[Music]
he is My Heart
Lord he is My Heart
Lord Is My Heart
Lord speak what is
true as I am found
I am
yours I am
th I make
pure I have
life I can
bre I am
heal I am
free Here My Heart
Lord is my Heart
Lord Is My Heart
Lord speak what is true
[Music]
I am found I am
found I am
your I am
love I'm in
P I have
life I can
re I am
heal I am
you are
strong you
are you are
life you
endure you are
good
true you are
Light breaking through sing here's my
heart is my heart
Here My Heart
Lord here my
heart speak what is
true is my
life my
life he my I
love speak what is
true speak what is
[Music]
true speak what
I am
found I am
yours I am
love I made
P I have
life
I I
I
am you are
strong you are
sure you are
life you is
your you
are for
true you
[Music]
are and you are
more than
you are
king you are
love you
are you
are you all I have you
every here
my he my heart
[Music]
Here My Heart
Lord see what
true he
my
my my love
speak what is
true speak what is
[Applause]
[Music]
true God we do ask you to speak truth
over us
where it's so easy to hear the voices of
criticism
disappointment
shame God where we put up walls would
you tear those down and speak to our
hearts
tonight Tear Down the Walls buil every
wall of build every wall of buil up cuz
you
deserve every pece of my heart every
pece of my heart every of my heart and
Lord I am trusting that you are
thankful father and all that you have it
is
good you're a generous G love like no
other won't you come and break through
over and over and over again I am
bringing my heart to you with open hands
closer and closer drawing me as the deps
of my heart before you again again over
and over and over again I am bringing my
heart to you with open
closer and closer
Dy the of my heart before you sing the
Lord
voice I am trusting you are faithful
brother told that you have his
good
you're SC with love like no other won't
you come and break
me over and over and over again I am
Brea my heart you with
open closer and closer you draw me as
the of my
heart you sing over over and
over I am bring my heart to you Open
Hands closer and closer
dra as the deps of my heart before
[Music]
you all that we have and all that we are
sing come come tear down the wall of
every bu every
[Music]
buve
every every of my heart every of my
heart te
down
every every
you deserve every
of every of my heart every of my
[Music]
heart is God you deserve
it not because you demand
[Music]
it but because you are good
because you are
worthy because you have first loved
us because you laid down your life on
behalf of the
broken because you came after us God
while we were yet
sinners so
tonight help us to open up our hearts
help us to connect with a God who is
love a God who has gone before
us a God who calls us
forward into light into life into
[Music]
hope we love you Jesus and we're
grateful for this time together we're
grateful for this community so please
keep doing your good work in our hearts
amen
you guys can turn to the people around
you say hello and uh welcome
them oh Grace and peace it is it's good
to be with you all to welcome you into
this space
and as always that includes those
joining us online love y'all and don't
forget to get your communion stuff for
later and uh anyone here tonight who is
new thank you for for being here being
Among Us uh especially depending on you
know Church backgrounds and stories and
potential pain there uh it can just be a
lot uh coming into this space so just
know really really matters to us and
we're yeah we're um not just you're not
like tolerated like you're wanted you
know it's like we we love that you're
here and are grateful so um also I want
to give a quick shout out to anyone who
went to Center peace the conference this
past weekend yeah a few of you were
there it was it was beautiful a good a
good time uh being among our lgbtqi plus
all the all the letters of the alphabet
and uh her siblings in Christ and allies
and it was just it was a beautiful
beautiful weekend there uh just
celebrating and it made me really
grateful for this community I'm always
um the way one of the speakers put it
one night um talking about church
communities and you know ones that are
open and affirming and uh you know not
just kind of welcoming of all but but
really inclusive and uh of all said uh
he just said you know spaces like these
uh really
matter and it was a good I don't know it
was just a good reminder to me of uh the
work we're doing here which you know
goes of course Beyond simply uh you know
Outreach to lgbtq folks but it's the the
point is that I think it's um at least
as honest an expression of the love and
Hospitality in the welcome of Christ as
we can do you know at least at this
point where we are in our own Journeys
and like that's that's where I think
that like this spaces like this it
matters it matters so I I think I just
want to say a big thank you to each of
you for the ways that you um participate
you know there's there's no Community
without people you know participating in
other just like an ideal or something so
uh so yeah your presence really it
really matters so we are um we're in a
series right now titled Jesus in
politics and um in week one we covered
uh the fact that Jesus you know perhaps
surprisingly was somewhat uh he was
critical of the kind of political
situation of his day uh everyone was
trying to kind of get him to like jump
in with both feet and become a
politician or a ruler a judge or you
know to just kind of play that role in
some way and he just kept kept
resisting and uh so then in week two we
looked at kind of the question this was
last week we looked at um why you know
why that was and we said it some it has
to do with the the kind of corrosive
nature of worldly power and and a kind
of power over
um that can easily slip into kind of a
control mode and that it tends to
corrupt you we even have little says
around this of how you know power
corrupts and absolute power corrupts
absolutely and you know we we all know
the the kind of danger of that that kind
of power over which is like almost
unavoidable perhaps is unavoidable in
kind of the political you know politics
in such um but we also said it kind of
has to do with an on what we called an
ontology of violence meaning that we
kind of tend to imagine the world as
kind of like in its roots as just
conflictual in nature you know like hey
there's love and joy and peace and
compassion all that Jesus stuff you know
oh that's nice that's nice but you know
that's like the that's on the surface
you know at the end of the day life is a
battle and there's good and there's evil
and we've got to win and you know and
that tends you can hear the in the kind
of intensity and um the mode that puts
us in we we tend to um get kind of
combative and coercive and so Jesus
comes to reveal something different that
really at its depths reality actually is
not conflictual um that at the very
roots of being itself is peace is
compassion is the god who is love this
is who Jesus comes to reveal which is
why he has to go you know when when
they're thinking we want you know the
disciples are thinking bring in the
Kingdom bring in the kingdom of God
bring in the dream of God for the world
make it a reality make it real you know
and they're thinking so take power how
else are you going to do it and he's
like cross
Resurrection Community you like is it's
like a very it's a different kind of way
you know so um this I think is what
Jesus came to reveal to us this this
kind of beautiful Invitational
non-coercive uh unconditional love but
um I want to kind of address some
questions that might come to mind in
light of that uh and that's where we'll
be kind of going this week so the title
of the message this week is plain
politics our passage is uh Matthew 5
38-41 where Jesus said you have heard
that it was said eye for eye and tooth
for
tooth but I tell you do not resist an
evil
person if anyone slaps you on the right
cheek turn to them the other cheek also
and if anyone wants to sue you and take
your shirt hand over your coat as well
if anyone for forces you to go one mile
go with them two
miles so in light of last week and even
if you weren't here last week in light
of that that kind of recap I just gave
and even in light of just this scripture
you know if you've come across it before
you you might have been left you know
with some questions there's like this
inevitably leaves questions in one's
mind of like okay yes you might say like
I can Brett I get it like I can see
how this this love like this is primary
you know and uh yes that is this is how
the kingdom will come primarily is is in
these ways uh through this this kind of
uh This Love Of Christ you know um
but but um like does that mean we are
like
literally like literally never to resist
evil like never I mean that's the text
right do not I tell you do not resist an
evil person like oh like if you really
right it's easy to kind of accept that
like I don't know like a cuty little
verse or something like oh yeah love and
stuff love you know great great and then
it's like but if you really stop and
think about that it's it's quite complex
and it might you again lead you to all
sorts of questions like how does this
look like never resist evil in any way
back on uh earlier this year Palm Sunday
I pre preached uh kind of on this theme
and I said this during that sermon I
said like Christ we too are invited in
the second half of life to trade the
warhorse of violence for the donkey of
humility the Throne of power for the
cross of gentleness the sword of force
for the word of blessing the ego
inflating path of pilot which is kind of
a picture right of politics for the ego
diminishing way of Christ and uh you
know in essence sort of Matthew 5 3841
doesn't really say much different than
that um
and it's but it's and really the series
right is getting at that but it's
interesting isn't it how contexts kind
of impact our hearing of things you know
I mean like in other words I preached
that message I don't know whatever it
was March or something and I think
pretty much no one would bat an eye you
know kind of like oh yeah yeah of course
of course right because in context right
leading into Holy Week we're thinking
like got a good Friday and then Easter
and it's like uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh but
you like take that same quote you know
what I mean and drop it in just before a
very important election and suddenly
it's like the hearts beating a little
faster you know I mean or getting a lot
of the the side eye you know I mean kind
of the I don't know about you know what
I mean and uh I think it's those kinds
of questions that are coming to mind
that kind of like uh I think in essence
that that's what I'm kind of wanting to
get at um because I think it it leaves
us uneasy but I I honestly I think it
leaves us uneasy for a good reason
and uh it's honestly it's hard questions
like these that the two books I've been
quoting throughout this series I judge
no one um by David dusenberry Reckoning
with power by David fit um those books
mostly leave these questions to the
side and I kind of hate that I I really
was not like if I have a critique of the
book that would be my critique was or
the books would just be like I don't
know I think you're you're like you know
kind of hinting at things you but never
really wrestling with like what does
this actually mean for Christian
communities you know like ours like how
do we actually live into this what does
this look like and uh like for example I
quoted David Fitch last week with this
quote he said the church seems prone to
blurring the powers in order to
accomplish God's justice we're ever
tempted to take the Reigns of top down
course of legislative power over to get
God's work done how do we learn from the
mistakes the white Evangelical Church
has made as it has capitulated to the
evils of slavery patriarchy economical
exploitation every time it has aligned
itself with worldly power how do we
avoid making the same mistakes in
relation to social conflicts that plague
cultures today so it's quotes of that
right where I get it like I get where
Fitch is where he's coming from he is
he's trying to speak to our cultural
moment um where he sees pretty clearly
what's happening right there there's a a
strong contention of Christians who are
pushing pushing pushing for something
like Christian
nationalism in the United States right
so so his book he's he's hitting against
that he's he's pushing back against that
and uh against this kind of naive idea
if we can just get the politicians on
our side then we'll you know we'll bring
in the Kingdom we'll uh we'll win this
country back for Christ or some other
such
foolishness and so right this is where
so Fitch is he has that in mind but he
is also writing to a largely post
Evangelical audience so he does have
communities like ours in mind because
this is his concern is that in opposing
that what will we do we will become its
mere image just from the opposite side
does that make sense so where it's it's
coming in this case from a more kind of
politically conservative angle we might
do it from a kind of more moderate or
kind of L leaning sort of place but
become a kind of inverted like in other
words I think Fitch could Envision a day
where there are I mean there are
millions of post evangelicals now right
so he can Envision day where there's
millions of post evangelicals who are
all as obsessed with political power as
the
Evangelical communities that they've
left does that make sense so that's
right that's his concern so so I get it
I get it um but as I named just a moment
ago this is where I think it's almost
like they see one danger you know but
sort of leave potentially the other
danger unaddressed which is why the
books kind of left me you know wanting
and um I mean in other words you know
does the call to follow Christ mean that
we never speak out when in
Injustice is
happening right that's kind of the some
of the question because oh is that is
that just coercive power over is that
you know playing politics is like is
there some way to you know avoid that um
is it simply kind of the use of a
different type of force does it mean we
should not you know vote which by the
way this is where like kind of Peace
churches and such who were kind of in
the anabaptist tradition who really like
Matthew 5 38-41 is like their Passage
you know the minites and others if
you're familiar with the Protestant
tradition and some of those kind of the
called it the radical Reformation like
there were folks who took like this is
the verse that as you enter their Church
it might be painted on the wall you know
like do not resist and so they're strict
nonviolence um many of them do not vote
be because they're not getting like M
we're not playing that game right so so
in essence and that's where fishes and
others are they're kind of drawing from
those Traditions um but is there kind of
a danger in the other side if we don't
you know ever Vote or protest or you
know perhaps even fight in a war and um
so I want to share with you tonight
where kind of where my mind's at on this
I'll leave it to you in meetups in our
small groups to kind of discuss and you
can discern where you are on it so just
because you know Pastor Brett says what
do you think you know I'm not it's kind
of say like this is the the word of the
Lord you know and don't you dare
disagree you know um you know that's not
really our
our Vibe our culture here so um so yeah
take this as food for thought all right
let's start um with an example that came
to mind when I was reading their books
and uh and even as I've read the words
of Jesus in Matthew 5 before I thought
of like take like the Civil
War you know how did slavery in this
country come to an
end
War that's that's the kind of of
uncomfortable truth so to speak you know
I mean of the other of of kind of a
perspective that would say like look you
you can't just kind of leave your hands
sort of up in the air like ah you know
what can we do like there's there
there's you know nothing good can ever
come from war or from a kind of power
over you know um or even I'm thinking of
like the uh to kind of stay along the
lines of racial Injustice think of like
the Civil Rights Movement you know that
yes employ void nonviolent protest but
protest nonetheless you know what I mean
like it wasn't a just kind of political
quietism of kind of like oh well no no
just waiting for the Lord you know to
work and as a spirit Le you know no it
was like out in the streets like stop it
you know I mean like it's it's let uh
let Justice you know roll like I'm
thinking of all the MLK speech you know
what I mean just and it's it's a kind of
there was in other words there yes
nonviolent but still a kind of force you
know in other words um you can say it's
not exactly like when you you know
boycott buses or um push for legislation
or mess up traffic or you know do
whatever even in the most nonviolent of
ways um it there it's still that's
that's different than say going two
miles when you're asked to go one mile
you know there is something in that
that's saying no you know like I've
walked two miles long enough you know
like now you're just taking advantage of
me you know the teachings ofes Jesus you
know that I'm being very patient with
you for like years and years and years
and now you're just taking advantage and
so no it's like a boundary you know I
mean like no I'm not walking another
inch not one more you know and and and I
know from the Peace church tradition I
know they would say like well that's a
problem you know you're disobeying the
words of Jesus and such um I'm not so
sure I'm not so sure that's a problem I
I I think
um I I
think there's a uh
a
time for those kinds of boundaries I do
I think there's a time for saying like
look no no enough you know not going to
not going to walk another mile Perhaps
it is I mean it is it kind of inways the
the literal reading of the text it is in
contradiction to that you know um and
yet um boy sometimes this world is so
jacked up and so messed up that in
essence to remain silent you know can be
in a way to end up aiding
evil you
know or take a more contemporary example
I'm thinking of like the way our trans
friends you know are being used
politically uh to stir up that fear and
dread I think the um certain politicians
know gay rights and such that's that's a
done deal um at least for now you know
it's a done it's it's that that issue
doesn't stir up the same kind of you
know gay marriage can you believe it you
know it doesn't I think there's too many
folks out people have too many
relationships now with like my cousins
out and they seem to be nice you know
like there's it doesn't do the same
thing trans though you know that still
gets certain people's hearts beaten and
there's you know fear and confusion and
so it's it's still politically viable
you know and so what are they doing
there there's this kind of um using the
vulnerable you know in these ways I mean
I'm sure you've all seen the commercials
that just infuriate me every time and
just like just throw a rock through my
TV you know just
um so is it wrong you know in that
instance to speak up to push back to
play politics you
know I think um no I think there there's
these points we reach where we say you
know my my silence will um
that actually just might be the greater
danger right in other words you realize
the danger on the other side right which
is to dusenberry and fit's point and I
think where Jesus is coming from where
we can kind of see once you start
playing the power game you know and kind
of trying to force and like you know
like once you start doing that like yes
it is it gets tricky real fast no doubt
like it can potentially create a
backlash you get cycles of you know
retaliation and you know Force tends to
meet Force like for sure so you
acknowledge all that danger um and yet
at the same time say you
know I I don't know
how how to avoid it you know it might be
like I think this world kind of presents
us at times with we do the least worst
thing we can do wouldn't that be nice if
we could always do just the best thing
you know I mean the right thing you know
just yes and we just feel real confident
in ourselves and you know it's it kind
of sucks but sometimes I think you just
do the least worst I think of uh the
story of Dietrich Bon Hofer is um really
instructive here so for those who don't
know um Bon Hofer he was a brilliant
brilliant German Theologian uh wrote the
cost of discipleship read by I mean
probably hundreds of thousands of people
even to this day um had just a great
mind also um a gay man by the way uh for
his own time very closeted and such we
know from his letters though um fell in
love with his best friend and uh so
early on though he saw so he's situated
in Germany you know 1920s 30s 40s so he
saw really early what was happening in
Germany thing was Bon Hofer was an
avowed pacifist so all about the
nonviolence all about Matthew 5 38-41
like he was like all in um and even
encouraged his student there where he
was teaching like to kind of gently be
begin the kind of process of kind of a
protest but non-violently and you know
but when Hitler's kind of coming to
power and such and started kind of doing
that that kind of thing uh but
eventually he could
see that uh in fact you know Hitler was
like a madman and like he just might win
the war and might take over the world
you know and so what did Bon Hofer do he
uh he not only joined the resistance
movement he got involved in a plot to
assassinate
Hitler and ultimately this is how he
died because uh they were almost
successful too by the way like it was
close um but he ended up getting caught
by the gapo sent to a concentration camp
uh and that's where he died in fact you
can read today his letters and papers
from prison another wonderful collection
of like incredible writings
um and what what strikes me though about
about his story is the way he described
his actions right because in essence he
would you know again read dusenberry and
David fit's books and read Jesus in
Matthew 5 and like not Al like yes yes
like this is the heart of the Gospel
this is the the best you know like this
is the idea like this is how we should
do it like this this is how the kingdom
comes you know um and
yet you know even going Beyond kind of a
non-violent protest like all the way to
we got to try to kill him you know like
it got like that kind of level so how
did he do so here's what's interesting
he described his actions um I think it's
in letters he describe it as a quote
necessary
sin isn't that
interesting um which I don't think here
sin kind of in a I don't know some
people with that word you know is like
very condemnatory I don't think he's
saying like I'm awful I'm terrible I'm
such a sinner I'm just word he's not
that I think I think it's more like he
understood the whole least
worst thing
um I like that language though because
of the the sense what I appreciate about
it um for him or from him is the sense
of depth there like that's some serious
thoughtfulness and a deep sense of
responsibility for what he's
doing and there's it's interesting how
there's no language there of you know
holy war for example there's no language
in his writings I'm taking Germany back
for God you know or some such foolish
like again he does no no it's a kind of
humble
Clarity where in in a profound kind of
moral wrestling with the question what
does this moment call for me to
do and then took responsibility for
that and then plunged
forward in a kind of
courageous
action or um you know take those moments
or I'm thinking even of this example
this like always comes up anytime you're
having kind of the nonviolence you know
conversation it's like well what if what
if someone they break into my home and
they're like I'm going to hurt your kids
you know what do I do then like do not
resist an evil person uh uh uh uh uhuh
don't you know I mean like I'm going to
hurt them I'm going to you know like
this is just um well this is where
Christians have had to wrestle with
these types of things though you know
and again where where I think we have to
go is um well at what point is my
refusal to do that am I actually aiding
and perpetuating more
violence you know and that's the that's
the thing we have to kind of wrestle
with that the ambigu it of that or take
those moments when uh many of you uh you
know headed out to the streets in
protest a few years ago of some
injustice you know say like black lives
matter or maybe today um it could be you
know trans rights matter or something to
that effect right that's a long way from
war surely you know uh but it is it is
for sure you know playing politics it is
for sure resisting evil it is you know
at least a touch of as we talked about
last week that metaphor of the ring of
power from Lord of the Rings you know
it's it's for sure kind of starting to
you know take that and wield it a little
bit um but I think it's those
moments when just like dedric Bon Hofer
we kind of have to take some
inventory and we have to with Clear
Eyes say okay okay I know what I am
doing I know what I'm
doing but I'm doing it you know I'm like
here we go I'm I am I'm choosing to play
politics I'm choosing to protest I'm
choosing perhaps uh even you know to
maybe kill in war or something to that
effect but I realize what I'm doing and
in this extreme situation I feel it is
the least worst thing I can do
we might put it like this sometimes
political power over in the form of
petition legislation protest and in
extreme circumstances even War may be
necessary however they should never be
done in a triumphal
Spirit right can you hear that's like
the difference because you might I don't
know hear this me message and think like
well you just went back on like
everything you preached you know
previously like it's just the you know
we end up the same place in essence like
so what's the point you know um but I
think there is a difference because I
think whereas before we might have very
thoughtlessly wielded that ring of power
might just been like hey just and and
been perhaps
overconfident in in how much good
force and uh politics and such could
even do you know here the the vision is
um a little more like politics and and
uh worldly structures and hierarchies
and forms and Things become a kind of um
stop Gap in other words I don't think
these things are how the kingdom will
come like just wait till we get the most
perfect
government and oh it's G to be good you
know or just like the Garden of Eden all
over again like no no um
but it's like a it's yeah it's it's like
a fall back it's like in this Fallen
World um this is kind of a reality we
have to Grapple with so I think the
difference is we become uh way less
triumphal uh way less uh sort of maybe
even optim a little maybe
pessimistic about the powers that be in
such and yet at the same
time uh a clarity about the kingdom
clarity about our primary calling and
then we we work with those two worlds as
best we can uh not easy that's why I say
you have to discuss the meetups to kind
of discern where you are uh what you
believe on this but um I I think
somewhere in this kind of messy middle
is uh the truth so you know I wonder how
this might impact your own kind of
involvement in this this whole election
season I mean I could imagine maybe
someone who uh really has been just very
hands off you know very like quiet and
just like no don't say I don't you know
and I don't know
maybe maybe you're nudged forward
towards like you know I might actually
need to be more vocal um I might need to
get more engaged or maybe the reverse
maybe you've been like wielding that
ring of power you're just like ah Smite
them you know and you realize like oh
okay maybe I need a little more a little
more thoughtfulness in how I'm I'm going
about this um but regardless I I hope at
the end of the day um it encourages in
us a
soberness a uh a
humility but perhaps also a
decisiveness in our actions that maybe
hopefully do in fact remind others of
the aroma of Christ in the world in the
name of the Father the Son and the Holy
Spirit
amen
so on the night Jesus was betrayed he
had one final meal with his disciples
and during that meal he held up a loaf
of bread he broke it he said this is my
body it's broken for you and he held up
a cup of wine he said this is my blood
it's shed for you whenever you eat this
bread whenever you drink this cup
remember me so as as we come to the
table of the Lord tonight as we take in
his body his blood may we be filled with
the spirit may we receive the
nourishment we need the wisdom we need
to know how to live and speak and um
walk
out this season God has Us in so the way
we'll take communion tonight is uh we'll
be forming one row right here in the
middle and we'll just start with the
front row and kind of work our way back
we practice what's called an Open Table
meaning if you're here tonight and you'd
like to participate then you are free to
do that having said that there's no
pressure If you're in a place where
you'd rather not you know that's fine um
you should know the red is wine the
white is grape juice and then finally
you can just partake whenever and
however you'd like so this is the
table not of the church but of the
Lord and it's made ready for those who
love him and for those who want to love
him more so come you who have much faith
and you who have little you who have
been here often and you who have not
been here long you who have tried to
follow and you who failed come because
it's the Lord Jesus himself who invites
you and it's his will that those who
want to meet him should meet him here
come to the table
[Music]
for
I
[Music]
would you guys go ahead and stand with
us we're going to close out this service
with a song called Christ be all around
me and as uh Brett was sharing his
message I don't know if you guys are
familiar with this passage but there's a
phrase um in scripture that says not by
might not by power but by my spirit says
the Lord and um I hope that that's kind
of our prayer and and as we sing this
song together and we go into our weeks
um would we be looking for the spirit of
God to be our
motivation that that would guide us and
direct us and uh light our
[Music]
paths as I
Rise strength of God
go
before lift me
up as I
wa Eyes Of
[Music]
God look
upon be my side
[Music]
as I
wait Heart Of
God
satisfied and
sustain as I
hear voice of
God lead me on
be my
God be my
God above and below me before and behind
me in
every sees me Christ be all around me
above below me before and behind me in
every I se you Christ be all around
me as I
[Music]
go
God my
defense by my
side as I
[Music]
rest of God
for
[Music]
the bring me
peace bring me
[Music]
peace above
and before and behind me in every eye
that sees me Christ be all around me
above and below
before and behind me in every ey that
sees me Christ be all around
me
oh
oh Christ be all around
me oh
[Music]
oh Christ be all
the your life your dead your blood was
shed for
every
moment every moment your life
your death your blood was shed for
every
moment every moment your life your death
your blood was shed for every
[Music]
moment moment your life your death
blood was shed for every
moment
every
[Applause]
moment above and below me before and
behind me in every eye that sees me
Christ be all around me above and below
me
before and
behind in every is
SE Christ be all around
me
oh
oh I see all around
me
oh oh
oh Christ be all the
[Music]
me well thank you all so much for
joining us this evening if you are new
here we would love for you to fill out a
visitor's card it's on the little table
as you leave or you can scan the QR code
and look for that visitor form
online we can all use more relational
support and spiritual connection and the
way we do that here at the table is
through our meetup groups so if you're
not yet part of a Meetup you can scan
the QR code to find one that will work
for
you generosity is a key component aspect
of life of adoration and
[Music]
worship um can't read my own
handwriting so uh if the table is your
church and you would like to help us out
financially you can scan the QR code or
you can go online at the table tx.org
all right let me send you off into your
week with this
blessing you can hold out your hands in
a posture of receiving or you can just
open your heart to these
words you are a child of
God you are a child of God this is true
true on your best day and it's true on
your worst day so as you go into your
week ahead with it's yet to be
determined highs and lows and everything
in between go filled with the assurance
that you are
loved that you are
worthy that you are respected that you
are accepted just as you are and go
filled with God God's Holy Spirit and
the desire to extend these same Gifts of
Grace and unconditional love to everyone
you come in contact with be blessed have
a good week and we'll see you back here
next
[Music]
Sunday before and
behind in every
SE Christ be all
around above and
below before and behind me in every ey
who sees me Christ the
all
me
oh
oh Christ be
all me
yeah oh
W
oh Christ be all around me
[Music]
you
good
e
e for